bonsoir à tous je sais que vous êtes de
plus en plus nombreux et c'est pour ça
que c'est avec plaisir que finalement on
n'est pas en visio ce soir mais qu'on
est ça le canut et la dernière fois nous
étions avec geneviève darrieussecq et
les questions ont fusé j'espère que ça
en fait j'en doute pas ce soir ça va
également fusé puisque ce format à vos
questions c'est vraiment voilà de l'
échange direct de les changes comme on a
envie d'avoir
et ce soir nous avons un invité qui a
plein de facettes un invité rock'n'roll
un invité si on devait le qualifié qui a
été un vrai militant un militant de
terrain d'abord parce qu'il a été très
jeune élu maire il a été maire a 29 ans
et ça a duré 26 ans c'est dire que il
devait être bon et puis il n'y avait pas
que ça patrick c'est aussi parce
qu'évidemment dont nous sommes avec
patrick mignola ce soir patrick il a
également été conseiller général dès
l'âge de 26 ans il a été conseiller
régional et aujourd'hui il est député et
en plus il a la grande charge parce que
oui c'est une charge moi je peux vous le
dire il est président du groupe modem à
l'assemblée nationale patrick mignola
c'est quand je disais au début c'était
d'abord un militant c'est d'abord un
militant
c'est parce qu'il s'est engagé il s'est
engagé dans des combats électoraux il
s'est engagé pour défendre des idées
comme beaucoup d'entre nous il a
commencé très tôt il a commencé dès
l'âge de 16 ans et des vingt ans il a eu
ses bases et ses premières
responsabilités au sein du parti il a
été président des jeunes républicains et
sa date de 80 ans c'est dire
c'est là où il a en fait il a été dans
la grande famille de l'udf dans notre
grande famille c'est là où il a eu ses
premiers échanges et ses premiers
contacts avec quelqu'un que nous aimons
beaucoup évidemment je parle de françois
bayrou
et tout ça nous amène ce soir patrick a
finalement se mettre à nu d'une certaine
manière j'ai cru que c'était mon oraison
funèbre
mais je t'embauche paul dans le cadre de
mon enterrement parce que peut-être ça
très bien mais pas aidé tout au
contraire
au contraire c'est ta capacité à
t'engager ta capacité à créer à rebondir
c'est pour ça que il y avait une vraie
demande chez les militants de poser des
questions en direct en direct parce que
on sait que tu vas répondre cash que tu
as plutôt la réputation de ne pas être
langue de bois et c'est ce qui fait du
bien c'est pour ça que je vous invite à
poser vos questions sur le field et
twitter et facebook
en bas n'hésitez pas puisque je les
prends en direct et vous allez voir il
n'y a pas tellement de filtres donc
profitons de ces moments direct patrick
on voulait partager avec toi ce moment
pour parler de reconstruction de notre
pays de bâtir ce nouveau modèle social
nous avons vécu une crise qui est la
plus importante depuis 45
cette crise elle a pris plusieurs formes
une crise sanitaire mondiale
ensuite on a une crise on a une crise
économique le pays
notre pays notre gouvernement a fait le
choix d'un d'engagement de prises de
positions extrêmement forte et
extrêmement ambitieuse puisque on il a
grâce à des mesures que nous avons votée
à l'assemblée d'ailleurs et au sénat
injecter quasiment 4 460 milliards
d'euros c'est quasiment 20 % de notre
pib
parce que l'objectif premier c'était
préserver les emplois c'était permettre
à tout le monde de ne pas perdre son
emploi à cause de cette crise sanitaire
et la souffre d'une certaine manière
une reconstruction une relance qui va
arriver et tout ça à bousculer notre
société bousculer nos familles bousculer
nos territoires il a eu le pire et le
meilleur dans le pire et bien des peurs
des incompréhensions des démos des fois
un plus plus peut-être maladroit et le
meilleur ça a été des gestes de
solidarité des collectivités qui se sont
engagés des familles des associations
qui ont essayé de créer des solidarités
au plus près d'eux notre pays a
bouillonné notre pays a créé notre pays
est resté debout
soutenus par des élus soutenus par un
gouvernement qui a été très ambitieux et
finalement on est en train de se dire la
crise n'est pas tellement terminé
puisque on en sort nous sommes encore
dans une phase de déconfinement le virus
circule encore il faut faire attention
mais il faut reprendre notre vie notre
vitalité retrouvée finalement cette
capacité à rebondir
et bien c'est sur le rebond que nous
souhaitions te poser des questions je
vais
la première peut-être c'est finalement
pour toi c'est quoi le bilan de cette
crise y tu dois en tirer 1 et surtout
pour toi c'est quoi nos capacités c'est
quoi la kz le cap qu'il faut prendre
dans ce rebond pour notre pays c'est de
ces deux pas oublier pourquoi on a
accédé aux responsabilités autour d'
emmanuel macron je vais presque commencé
comme ça parce que bien sûr qu'il faut
relancer l'économie du pays
il faut la relance éviteront la relance
et parce que ce sont les plus fragiles
de la société qui souffre de la
situation économique dans laquelle on
est folle à relancer vite parce que
chaque jour qui passe en dette nos
enfants a très bien redonner les
chiffres et il nous faut les uns les
autres nous remobiliser pour pour
retrouver une vie économique normale
mais sans oublier que la crise sanitaire
et la crise économique
c'était avant le coc vide une crise
démocratique une crise morale et donc
s'y ressource il y a il ya je crois le
la chance d'être un grand pays parce
qu'on le dit jamais assez le la chance
d'avoir des français qui ont montré
beaucoup de civisme et la question c'est
pas de savoir si c'est le gouvernement
ou les maires et les préfets qui nous
ont sortis de la crise la question c'est
d'abord de remarquer que ce sont les
français qui se sont sortis de la crise
parce que c'est eux qui par leur civis
par leur action par leur solidarité nous
ont permis de passer ce mauvais épisode
mais s'il ya un objectif à se donner
on viendra toutes les mesures techniques
en matière économique évidemment mais
c'est de se dire cette relance
elle doit être économique mais elle de
ne pas nous faire perdre le fil de là où
on doit aller si on est arrivé aux
responsabilités c'est parce que il y
avait une crise morale très profondes
dans ce pays et au fond si depuis des
mois on a vu des avocats jeter leurs
robes parterre des enseignants jeter des
cahiers par terre et la semaine dernière
des policiers jeter des menottes par
terre ça doit nous interroger sur le
fait qu' il n'y a pas que l'argent dans
la vie et qu'il faudra refaire de
l'argent mais que faudra aussi refaire
de la vie et quand tu dire faire de la
vie c'est finalement
c'est solidarité que tu viens d'évoquer
pour toi quelle quelle forme
comment comment les comment les garder
plus pérenne comment faire que demain ce
qu'on a pu voir sur nos territoires
soient beaucoup plus peut être régulier
comment faire confiance encore plus à
nos territoires
on se pose cette question de finalement
notre modèle démocratique
comment peut-être l'améliorer comment le
fluidifier c'est peut-être des questions
assez simple mais qu'il est de notre
quotidien et donc on s'est saisie et que
raison de dire c'est bien les français
qui sont sortis de cette crise parce
qu'ils se sont saisis de la réalité de
cette période qui était quand même
dingue on peut le dire mais comment les
aider encore plus comment permettre à
chacun d'être un acteur moi je crois que
il faut rebâtir un pacte social parce
que je dis souvent pour repartir il
faudra mieux répartir et les françaises
et les français repartent iront d'autant
plus vite dans la production et la
productivité économique retrouveront
confiance pour consommer plus ensemble
demain réinvestiront dans l'économie de
ce pays si et seulement si le progrès
est partagée est donc bien sûr que on a
une solidité économique qui nous faut
retrouver bien sûr qu'on sait que il
faut qu'on ait de la relance et en
particulier une relance par la demande
parce qu'on sait que c'est ça qui manque
aujourd'hui on sait qu'il faudra de la
relocalisation industrielle
on sait que il faudra donner des virages
écologiques qui sont devenus enfin un
peu plus possible parce que détruire du
capital pour le décarbonée c'est très
difficile quand on a un capital qui a
été déstabilisée c'est beaucoup plus
facile de le déclare bonnet parce qu'on
le fait redémarrer sur des bases
nouvelles
mais surtout il faut réécrire un pacte
social et donc concrètement ça veut dire
qu'il faut que chaque français et chaque
français soit intéressé au sens premier
du terme à la relance c'est la raison
pour laquelle on défend tu le sais au
compte- modem mais désormais cette idée
a infusé dans toute la majorité et au
delà il faut que chaque point de
croissance
retrouvez chaque point de rentabilité
recouvrée dans les entreprises soit
mieux partagé entre capital et travail
sur les 20 dernières années la
rémunération du capital augmenté sept
fois plus vite que la rémunération du
travail mais c'est pas comme ça que ça
peut marcher
on s'était déjà fâché et que le travail
quand on avait fait les 35 heures c'est
qu'on avait expliqué aux gens que on
pouvait travailler 10 % mois en gagnant
la même chose aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
quand on écoute la droite elle nous dit
qu'ils vont être travaillées 10% plus et
gagner la même chose mais au fond c'est
la même faute parce que on explique aux
gens que l'on travaille n'a pas de vraie
valeur puisque finalement ils peuvent
travailler 10 % de moins ou 10 % + eyene
la même chose bannon faut que moi je
considère que le travail est une valeur
et si cette valeur permet de créer de la
rentabilité dans les entreprises de
créer de la productivité dans le secteur
public il faut qu'il soit rémunéré en
tant que tel et donc ce n'est pas
seulement une relance qu'on doit penser
c'est aussi une autre approche d'un
progrès partager tes propos commence
déjà à créer et à questionner puisqu'on
a les premières questions qui viennent
de laurent et de fatima et les deux en
fait se rejoint d'une certaine manière
fait mal dit comment on peut revaloriser
encore un peu plus des métiers qui sont
pas délocalisables et laurent lui
revient sur quelque chose qui me tient à
coeur et je te jure je ne vais pas
souffler à laurent la question mais ça
touche en réalité l'économie sociale et
solidaire et sa question elle est très
simple il dit comment accompagner une
économie plus juste comment accompagner
une économie qui créent et qui partage
qui partagent plus justement qui
finalement refait vivre ou réinvente une
sorte d' égalité fraternité à
l'intérieur de l'entreprise
je sais que ça tu fais tu le sais ça
nous tient à coeur on essaie de le faire
vivre
mais est ce que tu crois que demain
l'économie sociale et solidaire qui
encore aujourd'hui elle est entre 10 et
15% fonction des territoires 15% des
emplois
comment demain accompagné en fait cette
économie qui de fait n'est pas
délocalisable mais surtout kick ass est
dans sa culture
le partage de la richesse et finalement
le fait d'avoir l'humain au centre de
l'entreprise c'est aussi une manière de
venir corriger ce que tu disais c'est à
dire une sur rémunération du capital
plus que la création de la valeur
humaine le
le capitalisme c'est pas une valeur
morale c'est un outil donc c'est une
valeur qui a d'ailleurs ni morale n'est
ni immoral viol c'est un unique un
mécanisme amoral et donc la meilleure
façon de développer l'économie sociale
et solidaire c'est de mettre de
l'économie sociale et solidaire dans le
monde de l'entreprise
un des grands enjeux qu'on a devant nous
c'est que on analyse plus le les objets
sociaux des entreprises et leur
performance uniquement sur le plan
financier on a créé dans le cadre de la
loi pacte certain nombre d'obligations
qui sont au fond d'ailleurs des
obligations assez peu contraignante pour
les entreprises mais c'est de définir ce
que peut être le projet d'entreprise
au delà de l'argent du rebut d'une
entreprise c'est de faire de l'argent et
c'est très bien comme ça il n'y a aucune
immoralité à ça en revanche la
performance extra-financière ce qu' il
ya encore quelques temps on appelait la
rse ce que aujourd'hui on appelle le sg
écologie social gouvernance il faut
qu'on soit capable de l'écrire et on
rigole beaucoup des états unis en disant
tout ça c'est une espèce
d'ultralibéralisme uniquement économique
les etats unis sont en train d'écrire en
ce moment même une un cahier des charges
des règles de cotation de le sg ce que
nous ne faisons pas alors donc on vit
aujourd'hui dans un système économique
et financier où ce sont des règles
américaines qui permettent de faire de
la cotation financière on peut pas se
permettre que l'europe est notre pays en
particulier en europe passe à côté de
cette cotation extra financière et donc
moi je j'entends de tous les discours du
monde sur le fait qu' il faut être plus
sociales il faut être plus morale il
faut être plus écologique il faut être
plus partageur moi je pense qu'il faut
souder les plus concrets et qu'on soit
capable d'écrire dans la loi et de faire
vivre dans chaque entreprise et avec les
partenaires sociaux qu'on soit capable
d'écrire ce que peuvent être les
objectifs non financier d'une entreprise
et c'est là qu'on retrouve évidemment
les leviers de l'économie sociale et
solidaire et si on est capable de se
dire que le l'entreprise du 21e siècle
c'est forcément une entreprise de du
partage de la valeur et parce que de
toute façon c'est une structure
économique dans laquelle on travaille
dans le partage
on aura fait un pas de reconnaissance
vis-à-vis de tous les métiers parce
qu'effectivement comme le disait très
bien de la personne farida je crois
qu'ils posaient la question
la crise a montré finalement qu'on
revenait à une situation normale c'est
dire que c'est très sympa de faire de la
mondialisation c'est très sympa de faire
des échanges mais pour avoir quelque
chose à échanger et quelque chose à
échanger dans le monde entier encore
faut-il des gens pour le produire or
qu'est-ce qu'on a découvert pendant la
crise qui avait des producteurs qui
avaient des femmes et des hommes qui
étaient en réalité ce qui tenait hier le
président de la république les a les a
appelés ceux de la deuxième ligne mais
mais si on veut bien se rappeler la
déclaration des droits de l'homme ou
[Musique]
les sols distinction entre les êtres
humains ne doivent être fondées que sur
l'utilité sociale
je pense qu'on a l'occasion dans le
cadre de cette relance économique
en plus d'écrire ce que peut être cette
nouvelle histoire comment rattraper
comment ne pas laisser les américains
passaient devant nous en fait le sujet
il est là puisque il y a une envie de
notre pays en tout cas on sent cette
envie dans la société d'avoir plus de
partage d'avoir plus de démocratie à
l'intérieur de l'entreprise aussi et on
y participe puisque l'on est un certain
nombre de mesures qu'on a voté et entre
autres tu as cité la loi pacte est
effectivement c'est une
c'est une vraie avancée dans l'économie
quand on dit l'objet social de
l'entreprise
l'évolution de l'objet social de
l'entreprise a été un débat fondamental
aujourd'hui on a l'occasion de le mettre
en oeuvre
peut-être un petit peu plus vite
toujours dans la même lancée je crois
que tu entres tu es en train de
déclencher un cycle de questions sur la
place de l'économie
il ya deux ya deux questions qui ce qui
s'équilibre sait comment faire avancer
les marchés publics avec la notion en
fait de deux commandes comment faire
évoluer la commande publique pour
qu'elle soit peut-être intégrer des
clauses sociales des clauses locales et
et le l'idée simple c'est dire
finalement comment accompagner nos
producteurs locaux
comment permettre aux communes d'être
encore un peu plus décisionnaire sur
leur marché
ça c'est une des questions qui est
approfondi par laurent je vois que la
question est est plus longue mais ma
mission est aussi de la synthétiser de
l'art et de la rendre accessible et
l'autre élément qui est assez important
comme embarqué toute l'europe avec nous
puisque n'oublions pas nous sommes dans
un marché européen
et si nos réussites ces hausses ne
seront complètes que si c'est des
réussites européenne alors la question
sur l'europe c'est une question à la
fois complexes mais laquelle on peut
répondre en peu de mots c'est que si on
est capable nous de créer ce système de
de cotation de notation des performances
extra financière des entreprises
on pourra le généralisé à l'europe parce
qu'il ya intérêt non seulement je crois
qu'on partage avec un grand nombre de
nos partenaires européens ces valeurs là
mais en plus leurs pieds intérêt parce
que si les américains le font c'est pas
seulement par philanthropie
c'est aussi parce que c'est un
formidable levier
de de fidélisation et d'entraînement des
générations qui arrivent aujourd'hui sur
le marché du travail
la génération de mes enfants qui vient
sur le marché il travel veux pas
seulement gagner un salaire
elle veut aussi participer à la marche
du monde
est ce si demain on souhaite son
engagement et si on souhaite que que l
développe l'économie française et si on
a envie qu'elle reste dans une
entreprise ma fille si elle est la passe
est ce supplément d'âme forcément ça
marchera pas donc c'est pas seulement
une idée politique c'est aussi une idée
d'efficacité économique
comment on fait dans les marchés publics
reprenez le programme de bayrou en 2007
20% des marchés consacrés uniquement aux
petites entreprises locales
les américains ont voté leur small
business act en 1963 s'amuse de parler
deux fois des états unis parce que
finalement et on se rend compte que pour
un pays d'ultra libéralisme économique
dans bien des domaines ils ont ils ont
été supérieurs pour essayer d'orienter
l'économie dans le bon sens mais
consacrons 20% aux petites entreprises
pour pouvoir servir les petits les
naissances et les locales et la deuxième
chose c'est qui a pas besoin de loi
il ya besoin de responsabilité et de
courage chez les décideurs locaux
parce que on pourra faire toutes les
règles du monde mais quand on attribue
un marché public en disant on met 50 %
de la notation sur le prix 50% sur la
qualité technique écologique
environnemental social si on note le
prix entre neuf et dix sur dix pour
toutes les entreprises mais qu'on note
le la partie rse le sg de 1 à 5
en réalité on fait total
disparaître l'objectif de valorisation
de la qualité des entreprises en tant
que tel et dans toutes les dimensions du
terme
tout ça c'est que du courage c'est de
pouvoir venir aujourd'hui autour d'une
table d'une commission d'appel d'offres
en dix ans effectivement on va pas
surpondérer la question du prix on vient
de le voir avec les masques
il ya des entreprises à des groupements
d'entreprises qui sont créées partout en
france pour créer des masques grand
public aujourd'hui elle nous écrit déjà
en disant on va arrêter notre groupement
d'entreprises parce que on avait
complètement revisitée notre chaîne de
production pour pouvoir produire du
masque on peut pas le faire parce qu'on
a des collectivités à deux pas de notre
usine qui continuent d'acheter des
masques au vietnam bon si on veut de la
relocalisation industrielle
il faut qu'on ait la responsabilité des
élus locaux là je sais que c'est
compliqué puisque moi j'ai présidé pas
mal de commission d'appel d'offres et
qu'on peut toujours se dire il ya un
risque de contentieux et bakchich allons
devant un tribunal administratif et
j'attends que le porteur de contentieux
devant un tribunal administratif
explique même s'il est inférieur en
matière de rse
il aurait dû être retenu quand même
simplement ce qu'il faut que nous en
fasse effectivement un bon système de
cotation pour qu'ils soient opposables
et qu'on renvoie les immoraux à leurs
études
et bien voilà une piste très concrète
c'est une vraie proposition est
effectivement ça sécurisera peut-être
certainement même les élus locaux danser
dans leurs choix et dans leur décision
aujourd'hui on sait que 70% de la
commande publique cela commandes des
collectivités territoriales 70%
donc effectivement on peut insuffler on
peut donner les outils on peut sécuriser
le chemin et ensuite il faudra que les
élus locaux puissent l'actionner et
l'action' c'est pour ça que en fait il
ya trois nouvelles questions une qui
viennent de samia une qui vient de
myriam est à nouveau laurent qui
réitérer ça va dans le même sens c'est
comment accompagner nos entreprises
c'est primordial samia qui dit le projet
d'entreprise au delà de l'argent le
social business par exemple est
important et ça a de l'avenir comment
convaincre nos patrons français pour qui
sait pas si naturel que ça que
finalement c'est l'avenir et ça tu as
commencé à y répondre dans mais en fait
c'est simple
pourquoi aujourd'hui la signature
française a de la valeur
parce que nous avons un état qui est
stable nous avons un modèle social nous
avons un contrat social passé entre nous
et finalement cette stabilité cette
résilience de notre pays et notre modèle
social fait que notre signature à l'as
de la valeur et cette valeur il faut la
garder
donc les questions qui se pose c'est
comment on continue et appliqué il faut
appliquer dire non seulement faut qu'on
ait des outils objectif pour pouvoir
aider les entrepreneurs concrètement
quand on dit on fait la participation
moi je trouve intéressante le la
proposition de loi qui vient d'être
déposée par notre collègue olivia
grégoire à l'assemblée elle a dit on met
en place la participation même dans les
petites entreprises la participation aux
bénéfices
mais on ne demande pas aux entrepreneurs
de le faire on demande à la ddip la
direction locale des impôts de le
refaire le contrat de participation type
en matière d'intéressement c'est la même
chose il faut que les chambres de
commerce que les chambres de métiers que
les fédérations professionnelles donne
des accords d'intéressement type
après effectivement les patrons
prendront prendront pas moi je parie
qu'ils prendront parce que si on lord et
complexifie d'avis et que en plus de ça
ils ont envie d'attirer les salariés de
les conserver au maximum
maintenant ce cas là forcément ils
viendront sur ces sujets là mais tout
réside dans l'application
ce pays il est plein de bonnes idées les
parlementaires travaillent à peu près
convenablement surtout toi sahara mais
le problème c'est quand on vote des lois
on les applique pas je suis stupéfait
j'ai anciens on a fait on a revisité le
code du travail on était d'ailleurs très
content finalement on a pu en profiter
pendant locaux vides ce qu'à l'époque on
s'était fait moquer de nous parce qu'on
avait légiféré sur le télétravail
on a fait ça à l'été 2010 est finalement
il ya on était bien content de trouver
au moins ce premier cadre législatif et
réglementaire mais la plupart des
éléments qu'on a mis dans le
la réforme du code du travail la poster
sur des accords de productivité dans les
entreprises des accords de compétitivité
dans les entreprises le la capacité
qu'on a saisi dans pack de fer de
l'actionnariat salarié pour les
structures économiques quelle qu'elle
soit en fait personne ne l'a appliquée
et je me suis retrouvé l'autre jour
quand je faisais un déplacement dans un
département en face d'un président de
medef qui m'a dit bon il serait quand
même temps que vous réforme et
l'apprentissage
parce qu'aujourd'hui un menuisier peut
pas monter sur une échelle et j ai dit
c'est toi qui va tomber de l'échelle mon
garçon il faut quand même faire un peu
attention ce truc est réglée depuis un
an et demi
donc si tu m'aimes tu lis même pas les
lois qu'on fait à l'assemblée dont les
décrets d'application sont sortis et qui
effectivement ont sécurisé le toutes les
absurdités qu'on pouvait connaître parce
qu'effectivement ça existe et le
menuisier pas le droit de monter à
l'échelle ça existe et le boulanger qui
pouvaient pas aller à 5 heures du matin
avec avec son maître d'apprentissage
aujourd'hui sont la simplifier faut
juste s'en saisir je crois que c'est le
rôle des parlementaires
je crois que c'est le rôle des
mouvements politiques de le faire c'est
lé rôle des élus locaux et c'est le rôle
de tous les corps intermédiaires
parce que moi je vois bien que désormais
il faut qu'on revalorise sinon qu'on
vénère tous les corps intermédiaires
moi je fais pas de démagogie sur le
sujet je pense qu'on a besoin des corps
intermédiaires
parce que c'est comme ça que fonctionne
une société il faut que les corps
intermédiaires prennent aussi la main
quand on a la possibilité de les passer
très concrètement dans une entreprise de
42 salariés un accord d'intéressement
eh bien il faut que les partenaires
sociaux mais des fcpe u2 a d'un côté
cfdt cgt et fo de l'autre se mettent
autour de la table de leur parité
départemental et qu'ils fassent des
propositions pour ces entreprises là
parce que forcément ça se fera pas tout
seul parce que tout le monde a le nez
dans le guidon et à l'application celle
affaire de tous donc la loi elle peut
être voté par les députés faut que les
députés n'oublie pas qu'après ils
doivent la faire vivre sur le terrain
mais surtout que tous les acteurs
économiques qui je le précise au passage
jusqu'à avec pas mal d'argent public
faut qu'il soit aussi les ambassadeurs
et les acteurs de l'application je crois
que le message est bien lancée il est
clair mais c'est à ton habitude donc
tout temps tout à ton honneur et
d'ailleurs je vois les autres réactions
se poser est là la question du
télétravail
juste pour rappeler parce que beaucoup
de familles ont été confrontés en fait à
la l'organisation en télétravail à
s'adapter a finalement aussi prouver dès
fois à des managers que non il n'y a pas
de baisse de productivité quand on
télétravail ça ouvre un autre débat en
parallèle c'est à nouveau le droit à la
déconnexion comment la compagnie et
finalement tu as raison le télétravail
on la fait avancer dans la loi il ya
plus d'un an et on a rendu ce droit
opposable puisqu'aujourd'hui c'est bien
à l'employeur de refuser de motivé le
refus ce qui n'était pas du tout le cas
avant et c'est ce qui a permis deux
peut-être ce premier acte de confiance
cet outil il a existé et là on l'a
utilisé est-ce que tu crois
fondamentalement que pour notre économie
que le télétravail est un bon outil
qu'est ce qui manque aujourd'hui dans sa
mise en oeuvre
parce que c'est sait on l'a essayé en
entrée très large d'un coup mais on a vu
on en a vu le meilleur peut être les
premières limites aussi comment
l'accompagner en trait c'est une
question qui revient puisque beaucoup il
fonde beaucoup d'intérêt donc moi je
crois beaucoup que ça peut accompagner
notre économie est évidemment ça va
accompagner notre écologie parce que la
dérive qu'on connaît depuis 30 ans ou
par mauvaise habitude ou parce que les
élus locaux étaient pas persuadé de la
nécessité de la transition écologique et
énergétique ou parfois par l'acheter
parce que on autorisait des droits à
construire à 20 ou 30 kilomètres des
villes on se trouve aujourd'hui avec des
des acteurs économiques des salariés du
public comme du privé qui peuvent vivre
très loin de leur lieu de travail donc
le fait de limiter
les transports va aussi nous apporter
une réduction de l'empreinte carbone ce
qui manque aujourd'hui
en fait c'est une discussion à
l'intérieur des entreprises parce que le
télétravail ne remplace pas le travail
il faut qu'on se dise parce que vivre
dans une unité économique c'est aussi
avoir une vie sociale et pendant cette
crise au même titre que nos enfants ont
beaucoup souffert et on commence à en
voir les dégâts psychologiques
aujourd'hui ne pas aller à l'école ne
pas être socialisé de ne vivent qu'avec
des adultes et donc paradoxalement
qu'avec des soucis d'adultes ça a été
très compliqué pour les enfants et je
pense que c'est
c'est un des éléments sur lesquels aussi
bien les tacles et que les mairies
devront se remettre assez lourdement en
cause sur la responsabilité comportent
par rapport à cette génération là mais
au même titre qu'on a vu ça pour les
enfants on l'a vu aussi pour les parents
en télétravail
parce que quand on n'est plus dans son
entreprise qu'on n'est plus dans son
association qu'on est plus dans son
administration
qu'on travaille à distance oui on fait
le travail mais en fait on perd à la
fois le l'affectio societatis serre ce
qui fait que on a envie d'être ensemble
dans une structure économique quelle
qu'elle soit et puis on perd du lien
social
donc il faut à la fois qu'il ya une
discussion sur comment on est le plus
productif ensemble c'est pas un gros mot
donc et parfois effectivement ça peut se
faire à distance
il faut aussi que on observe que parfois
les entreprises avancent et les
mentalités aussi
et la vie sociale surtout aussi autour
d'une machine à café
est-ce que c'est pas interdit de voir
d'autres gens dans la vie que son
ordinateur et son conjoint même sur le
dos surtout quand elle adore c'est mieux
moi je je vais te poses des questions
peut-être sur un autre crush on a on a
parlé beaucoup d'économies beaucoup
d'entreprises mais beaucoup d'humain
dans l'entreprise et ce qui m'amène à
peut-être une autre
un autre prisme une autre facette de
comment bâtir un nouveau modèle comment
bâtir que reconstruire notre pays après
après ces moments violent qu'il a vécu
tu vas parler d'eux
la situation psychologique des enfants
déjà parlé effectivement des difficultés
des parents qui pour certains avaient et
à travailler et à accompagner les
enfants en même temps la promiscuité
aussi du confinement tout ça provoque et
évidemment des fois des eaux des fois
des bas dans les familles mais c'est
comme tous et c'est la vie un autre
sujet qui à bâtir c'est la question
démocratique on a parlé d'une crise
sanitaire on a parlé d'une crise
économique est aujourd'hui la question
démocratique a été posée et là je vais
aller sur deux points peut-être le
premier c'est que on a vécu et je pense
que ça a choqué beaucoup de français un
débat scientifique à la télé qui a
bousculé
c'est à dire qu'on avait deux
scientifiques quitté deux fois la même
deux choses contraires et donc qui a
fragilisé ce lien de confiance qu'on
peut qu'on peut avoir et qui est
nécessaire donc comment peut- être
réconfortés comment reconsolider puisque
là il ya un doute là il ya quelque chose
qui s'est passé et c'est pas c'est pas
mon avis en conséquence est le deuxième
point sur la question démocratique
comment faire vivre encore plus
fortement cette démocratie sur nos
territoires
on a vu la proximité des mères on a vu
leur leur capacité à se saisir on a vu
aussi une assemblée une démocratie qui
ne s'est jamais arrêté quelle que soit
la situation
le sénat sert à organiser nous à
l'assemblée nationale on a fait pareil
et bien finalement patrick comment
améliorer encore un peu plus ce lien de
notre côté je veux dire au niveau des
élus nationaux mais également au niveau
local je sais que tu travaille
énormément sur les questions aussi de
nos collectivités de notre démocratie et
je pense que te lancer sur ce sujet
permettra également à tous ceux qui nous
suivent et bien de de creuser cette
curiosité et d'aller vers des questions
qui complète puisque je sais que le
temps est compté mais j'aimerais bien
qu'ils découvrent plusieurs de tes
facettes je pense que la question
institutionnelle intéresse pas du tout
les français
ni les modes de scrutin ni les élections
ni le mille feuille territorial c'est
pas le truc qui fait partie de leurs
priorités
orange qui fait partie de leurs
priorités c'est un diagnostic qu'on peut
essayer de poser ensemble nous ne
faisons plus société au fond chacun se
vit et se déclare abandonné mal reconnue
dans sa singularité dans son effort dans
l'énergie qui consacre à lui-même à sa
famille à sa vie quotidienne à
l'ensemble de la société et il faut
qu'on réécrivent à cette société une
raison d'être faire société c'est avoir
quelque chose à partager avec les autres
et se dire que le projet politique que
peut porter ce pays qui peut réconcilier
les les égoïsmes pour qu'ils deviennent
pas des frustrations et des violences
comme on le voit trop souvent c'est de
se dire qu'on peut partager la richesse
on vient d'en parler on peut partager
les ressources et on doit le faire et on
peut partager les pouvoirs et c'est
seulement à ce titre que on pourra
attirer l'attention de nos concitoyens
sur le fait qu' on a un état qui marche
sur la tête en marche la tête c'est on à
57 % de dépenses publiques dans notre
pib
et pourtant on a eu le sentiment qui est
plein de dysfonctionnements pendant
cette période de crise mais
dysfonctionnements les connaissez avant
on les avait à dire dépiauter pendant le
grand débat après les gilets jaunes on a
besoin rien qu'en termes d'organisation
de l'état d'avoir des préfets qui est un
véritable rôle de coordination sur
toutes les autres administrations d'état
qui sont sur le terrain
tous les moyens sont là les personnes
sont là elles sont compétentes mais le
rituel sont mal coordonnés la première
chose qu'on apprend dans une entreprise
en termes de management celle des six
otages plus travailler en silo chacun
dans ses lignes de nage
bon si on est capable de faire ça au
niveau local on aura déjà avancées en
matière d'état déconcentrer il ya une
deuxième chose qu'il faut faire c'est
que on se retrouve pas à continuer à
prendre des décisions au niveau des
administrations centrales alors qu'elles
pourraient être mieux pris sur le
terrain
il ya en matière de santé on voit assez
bien les choses de ce point de vue là
après tout dire aujourd'hui le fait et
c'est une très forte demande de leur
part que les élus locaux puissent
participer à la définition de la
politique de santé publique sur leur
territoire ce qui pourrait permettre
aussi de mieux le doté financièrement
c'est extrêmement intéressant et et le
mille feuille territorial enfin on peut
pas continuer à vivre dans un truc où on
sait plus vraiment qui est responsable
de quoi
or il n'y a pas de il n'y a pas de
liberté d'organisation démocratique s'il
n'y a pas de véritables responsabilités
derrière et moi je rêve d'un truc c'est
qu'on dise à tous les élus locaux
souhaitent pas forcément un truc très
grand public mais on pourrait le faire
et que les élus locaux
et puis après le soumettre à nos
concitoyens je rêve d'un truc c'est que
région par région on met tous les élus
locaux dans une salle et qu'on leur dise
écoutez vous allez nous vous allez dire
à l'état ce que vous voudriez pouvoir
faire en plus ici ce sera les routes
nationales le laissera la santé là bas
ce sera le tourisme
jacqueline gourault a beaucoup travaillé
sur ces sujets là on est prêt ça
s'appelle la loi 3d des concentrations
décentralisation différenciation que
vous allez faire une deuxième chose vous
allez définir entre vous comment vous
allez assumer les responsabilités
d'aujourd'hui les responsabilités
nouvelles qu'on pourrait vous donner
demain
et selon les territoires ce sera pas
toujours la même réponse
parfois on se dire ah bah là il faut que
ce soit la région qu'ils soient chefs de
file parce qu'il ya besoin de d'une
puissance stratégique à cet endroit
c'est un petit département qui est assez
pauvre ya vraiment besoin une grosse
cohésion territoriale à celle
département à d'autres endroits au
contraire fois travaillé sur les
intercommunalités à d'autres endroits
encore faudra pas s'interdire de faire
redescendre au niveau de la commune
certaines responsabilités parce que dans
les zones rurales où on a fait à toute
force des intercommunalités un peu un
peu brutale et que on a un village tous
les 10 kilomètres ça fonctionnerait
mieux au niveau de la commune
qu'ailleurs et et que l'état donne plus
de liberté aux pouvoirs locaux mais que
les pouvoirs locaux acceptent d'assumer
cette liberté en répartissant mieux
leurs responsabilités en faisant
circuler ses responsabilités entre eux
je pense que ce serait un très grand
progrès et partager les ressources
partager la richesse et savoir mieux
partager le pouvoir
ça peut commencer à nous donner l'idée
d'un projet de société qui serait un peu
mobilisateur pour les temps qui viennent
tu parles de projet de société
mobilisateur et pendant tes propos les
questions qui reviennent c'est en fait
c'est fou et c'est rassurant à la fois
ça revient sur l'économie et ça revient
sur l'économie parce qu'en réalité
effectivement si on écrit on ne crée pas
de richesse on n'a rien à partager si on
si on n'a pas ce moment de sociabilité
et bien on est tout seul et il
yad'autres danger c'est la solitude le
fait d'être totalement décrochés et donc
deux sujets de sujets reviennent le
premier en plus un sujet qui te plaît
c'est l'industrie comment accompagner
notre industrie comment faire que pour
qu'elle soit encore plus performante et
leader et puis un autre qui est posée
par qui est posée par fatima qui dit et
comment on comment on repense nos
territoires
comment re portion de territoire avec
des économies qui sont en train de
changer comment on repense des espaces
pour du plus de télétravail mais quand
même avec des liens humains dont elle
parle du coworking et laurent qui pousse
juste un tout petit peu plus loin le le
sujet en disant mais finalement redonné
à la démocratie un nouveau modèle
politique est ce que ce serait une
nouvelle manière de s'exprimer
et là évidemment ça nous mènera sur le
troisième temps de notre échange je
pense que je le pense évidemment aux 150
propositions du conseil citoyen et
comment quelques pas quelle suite en
tant que tel mais quelle expérience quel
bilan tirer de cette magnifique
expérience comment faire vivre cette
démocratie participative à côté d'une
démocratie qui est une démocratie qu'est
la note d'une démocratie délibérative
une démocratie qui ne met pas de côté
mais qui laisse bien la légitimité par
l'expression démocratique par
l'expression du vote
donc ça c'est un troisième point que je
garde et sur lequel je reviendrai mais
ces deux points principaux
comment finalement faire
vraie économie et territoires contrat
social et aménagement local
alors il ya de temps le pass colère on a
beaucoup parlé des des valeurs de la
colonne vertébrale tno zone iv dans la
relance mais dans la relance il ya de
temps premier temps c'est un temps de
sauvegarde
il faut pas qu on s'effondre et on se
donne les moyens même d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui on commence à avoir des
retours statistiques sont intéressants
parce que la reprise serait un peu
meilleur qu'attendu et ensuite il y aura
le temps de deux du rebond en lui-même
dans ce temps là comment on ré
industrialiser avec une volonté
politique
moi je regrette beaucoup que depuis
montebourg on est intégré le ministère
de l'industrie dans le ministère de
l'économie
à chaque fois qu'on met un truc dans
bercy en général le mettant aux ordres
de ceux qui gèrent nos finances il y
perd beaucoup en liberté d'action et
avoir je crois que dans ce pays une
vraie stratégie industrielle qui soit
identifiée en tant que tel c'est à
hubert védrine ce matin qui faisait
d'ailleurs cet appel en disant il
faudrait qu'on ait un mystère
d'industrie exclusivement dédiée à la
relance ce serait intéressant et en quoi
ça rejoint les territoires nous avons
besoin de déclare bonnet l'économie
décarbonée l'économie c'est des cas
rooney l'énergie donc demain si on veut
des industries vertes
il faut qu'on ait des productions
énergétiques renouvelables
c'est précisément dans les territoires
les plus pauvres quant à pouvoir le
faire parce que produire de l'énergie à
partir de l'eau ça on le fait depuis
longtemps le faire à partir de la
biomasse le faire à partir de 2 des
productions de déchets industriels faire
en fait de l'écologie territoriales ça
passe très précisément dans des
territoires qui sont pas metropolis et
est donc si on est capable demain
d'avoir une volonté industrielle et une
énergie décarbonée
on est capable de les implanter là où on
souhaite faire de l'aménagement du
territoire ça peut pas simplement par
deux choses moi je pense que il faut pas
se contenter de faire des contrats de
plan état région pour la relance il faut
faire des contrats de plan
et à petit territoire et qu'on
investisse dans les petits territoires
qu'on descende dans la granule haut
parce que si on fait sa région par
région les territoires les plus ruraux
les plus fragiles sont pas forcément
touchés ça c'est la première chose
et la deuxième chose il faut toucher un
gros mot il faut toucher aux impôts de
production les impôts de production
c'est ce que c'est faux en tout cas les
entrepreneurs et souvent les salariés le
savent la c3 est la cvae l'acfe les
sigles horrible qui représente je le dis
comme ça au passage 78 milliards de
prélèvements sur les entreprises de ce
pays alors que l'impôt société qui est
payé tous les ans par les entreprises
celui qu'on voit le plus ne représentent
que la moitié
si on touche pas aux impôts de
production je sais pas comment on fait
de la relance industrielle et de la
relocalisation industrielle cc
extrêmement sympathique de dire qu' il
faut fabriquer des masques et des
pharmacies et des médicaments sur le
territoire français je soutiens cette
idée mais on va vite nous expliquer que
par définition si son parti dans
d'autres pays c'est parce que ces autres
pays avaient pas la même fiscalité et ça
ça passe par un new deal fiscale avec
évidemment les collectivités locales
puisque les impôts de production sont la
ressource principale des collectivités
locales je pense qu'elles sont dans un
moment où elles ont compris que
l'important ce n'est pas de savoir si on
avait une cv ou à une part de tva parce
que ça souvent été les discussions qu'on
avait dans les comités de finances
locales mais que l'important c'était de
pouvoir recréer des emplois dans le pays
ou de conserver ce qu'on a déjà
donc c'est ça va être ça le vrai enjeu
des discussions des mois qui viennent
eh bien tu vois en allant sur les impôts
de jeu est impropre dussault tu as
répondu à une question qui a été posée
avant même finalement que je te la pause
c'est que ceux qui sortent ce qui est en
train de se passer aujourd'hui en direct
et les changes que nous avons avec vous
derrière vos écrans finalement c'est
qu'il ya une vraie connexion c'est
plutôt rassurant puisque rien que je
connaisse et c'est bien parce que du
coup je te dédicaces quand même la
réponse qu'il a que patrick a apporté
patrick je vais on va on va aller sur la
troisième phase peut-être le troisième
le troisième sujet c'est les 150
propositions de la convention sur le
climat
ça a été un moment de démocratie
participative assez intéressant
c'est inédit on sortait quand même d'une
crise la crise des gilet jaune avec
beaucoup de grands débats de grands
débats sur nos territoires qui ont
permis au pays de s'exprimer et sur
chaque territoire il ya eu en fait ce
moment cette respiration
cet échange cette construction
volontaire sauf que le grand débat qui
se pose c'est il ne faut pas opposer
démocratie participative et démocratie
représentative
mais comment faire converger comment
tirer le meilleur de cette intelligence
collective et finalement deux de ses
propositions qui sont sans apporter
aucun jugement qui traite de beaucoup de
sujets et qui arrive voilà avec une
conclusion
l'idée c'est de dire toi quelle est ta
perception de cet exercice
qu'est-ce-qui caisse quand c'est quoi le
meilleur c'est quoi peut-être le pire
et finalement ce qui m'amène à dire et
si on doit refaire comment re frais moi
j'ai une perception très positif de
l'est convention citoyenne
d'abord dans sa composition parce que
ceux qui ont été élus locaux ou tout
simplement conditions des citoyens
engagés dans leur commune ont vécu dans
des outils de démocratie participative
qui était beaucoup moins performant que
paradoxalement pour que la démocratie
participative fonctionne il faut qu'elle
soit représentative et il ya eu un vrai
travail scientifique fait par la
convention citoyenne pour que les 150
citoyens qui se sont retrouvés soit
vraiment représentatif de la france soit
une une france en petit parce que on a
veillé à ce que il représente le plus
équitablement possible les territoires
les formations professionnelles les
situations familiales et donc c'est déjà
ce travail qui a été fait alors que
quand on convoque un comité de quartier
dans une commune vient qui veut à peu
près toujours les mêmes la moitié étant
des opposants ou des lobbyistes
là au moins il ya quelque chose qui a
été
scientifiquement participatif donc je
trouve que c'est une démarche positive
en soi après je crois surtout qu'il faut
pas s'arrêter sur les deux ou trois
provocation inacceptable dit des choses
vraiment sans tourner autour du pot
parce que ces 150 citoyens en reprenant
tel quel des propositions qui était
faite par un certain nombre d ong depuis
vingt ou trente ans où on annonce fixées
sur des petites marottes et ben
finalement elles ont attiré le l'opinion
publique uniquement sur un ou deux trucs
qui était quasiment des provocations et
on n'a pas vu tout ce qui était
important dans les autres propositions
mais ça fait rien moi je suis un éternel
optimiste
les 110 km heure c'est une connerie
enfin c'est une connerie en soi déjà
parce que on peut le faire
je rappelle que dans toutes les
agglomérations il ya des plans pour
l'air il ya des plans climat et le
préfet peut d'autorité décider des cas
un pic de pollution ou même quand il
n'ya pas de pic de pollution d'abaisser
de 20 km heure toutes les routes et pas
seulement les autoroutes les nationales
aussi des départementales des communales
j'observe d'ailleurs que c'est pas une
immense avancions dans le vous allez
dans le centre de londres
il ya des endroits où vous pourriez vous
pouvez rouler au maximum à 15 heures et
seulement à l'électrique donc vient
c'est pas la pensée du siècle mais en
revanche pour être sûr de faire
s'engueuler les français parlé lors de
la vitesse sur les routes
donc voilà je pense que c'est c'est une
proposition dommageable au sens où
finalement c'est l'arbre qui cache la
forêt parce que moi on parle que de ça à
chambéry il ya une deuxième il ya un
deuxième élément qui me paraît plus
grave et en même temps qui peut être une
formidable opportunité
c'est l'inscription dans la constitution
que d'autres libertés serait limitée à
l'empreinte écologique comporte cirque
on est libre de vivre comme on veut sauf
si nous portons atteinte à
l'environnement telles qu'énoncées ainsi
moi je suis plutôt d'accord c'est assez
légitime
il faut que on prépare une terre
meilleur pour nos enfants
mieux que nous que les générations
précédentes l'avait fait dire aussi les
choses franchement
mais inscrire sa dans la constitution
au fond c'est considérer qu'on peut
vivre demain dans une société
restrictives de liberté où on est un peu
moins humains et tous les combats de ce
pays depuis des siècles c'est au contrat
de donner plus de liberté et donc c'est
pas ans ajoutant des contraintes moi
j'ai pas envie de vivre dans une
dans une société où pour quel que soit
l'objectif pour quel que soit le la
valeur qu'on veut défendre on
restreignent la liberté des gens et au
fond on est en train de parler de quoi
en en train de parler du débat qui ait
jamais été tranchée en matière
écologique est ce qu'on est capable de
faire de l'écologie
seulement si on est des croissants ou
est ce qu'on peut faire de l'écologie de
croissance qui est compatible avec la
liberté le progrès humain moi je crois
que c'est possible parce que demain on
peut avoir une analyse de la croissance
qui est beaucoup mieux qualifiés qui
n'est pas seulement financière et puis
analysons les choses si on veut bien se
considérer comme étant dans le camp du
progrès
l'idée de progrès au moyen-âge était pas
libre et l'idée qu'on pouvait avoir
autant de la machine à vapeur
pas plus qu'au xxème siècle et celle que
nos petits enfants auront dans quelques
temps c'est à nous qualifier ce qui est
un progrès c'est à nous qualifier ce
qu'est la croissance plutôt qui expliqué
qu'ils aient finalement y'a pas
d'écologie sans malthusianisme et donc
moi je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
propositions opérationnelles qu'on peut
traiter au parlement ou que le président
décidera peut-être de traiter par
référendum ce que je pense des deux
provocation majeur 110 km heure
orange et ça dans un tiroir et en
reparler le jour où on aura vraiment par
parler d'autre chose ou qu on s'ennuiera
et la deuxième chose sur l'inscription
dans la constitution d'une restriction
de liberté doit être l'occasion d'ouvrir
un vrai débat parce que si d'aucuns
pensent qu'on fera de l'écologie
seulement si on est mal cuit siens si
demain on s'interdit de faire des
enfants et de vivre comme on veut moi je
pense qu'on va pas dans la bonne
direction et en tout cas c'est pas comme
ça qu'on entraînera les français au
passage
j'observe que ça nous permettrait de
régler deux sujets que la convention
citoyenne a mis de côté premier sujet
c'est celui de l'énergie
je les ai dit tout à l'heure pour faire
une économie décarbonée il faut qu'on
ait une énergie décarbonée la convention
citoyenne n'a pas voulu parler des
questions liées au nucléaire ou à
l'hydroélectricité
moi je souhaite évidemment que demain le
nucléaire l'hydroélectricité pour pas
faire trop de barrage puisse être
remplacée par des énergies propres et
renouvelables
mais tout ça va durer cent cinquante ans
on aura pris le chou avant et donc
trancheront le sujet il ya deux
solutions soit on fait encore appel
pendant quelques décennies au nucléaire
est évidemment à l'hydroélectricité
savoyard qui vous parle
et c'est comme ça qu'on ira vers une
économie décarbonée
ou alors ou alors il faut décider qu'il
faut consommer tellement moins d'énergie
qu'il faut qu'on s'interdise de vivre
librement et de faire des enfants de la
même façon sur l'artificialisation des
sols
moi je suis parfaitement d'accord sur le
zéro artificialisation honnête cirque on
ne doit plus construire sur des espaces
naturels sur des espaces agricoles
mais j'observe que tous les maires qui
vont se faire élire quelle que soit leur
étiquette ont tous annoncé qu'ils
voulaient des densifier les villes d
bettoni zélés ville si on reconstruit
pas la ville sur la ville si on n'avance
pas des densités heureuse et végétalisé
dans les villes par définition on ira
taper dans les espaces naturels et
agricoles sauf si on s'interdit d'être
libre et si on s'interdit de faire des
enfants
et ben moi je veux une société libre je
vais une société où on peut faire des
enfants où on est pas mal tu viens et où
on sait inventer une croissance
qualifiée une énergie décarbonée et des
villes qui se développe sans taper dans
l'agriculture périurbaine et ben ça fait
30 ans que ce débat sur l'écologie n'a
pas eu lieu
ça fait 30 ans qu'on dit y'a qu'à faut
qu'on ait plus vite
mais si on veut faire vraiment mais
posons le débat assumons le et c'est
maintenant qu'on peut le faire donc la
convention citoyenne
cet enfant là et bien encore une fois tu
as répondu à claudine parce que pour
elle elle voyait mal comment faire de
l'écologie et de la croissance en même
temps et sauf que ce ne s'oppose pas au
contraire ça converge et ça converge
même très bien si on veut une société où
nous sommes quand même libre et ça vient
compléter les propos en réalité de
laurent qui dit n'oublions pas que nous
ne sommes pas seuls sur la planète
et effectivement c'est en permettant
cette convergence en embarquant les
autres pays européens avec nous c'est en
permettant à chacun d'adhérer et de ne
pas s'opposer c'est comme pour le pays
plus on le rassemble mieux ça marche
plus on n'oppose plus on divise et plus
on mettra d'énergie dans des combats qui
sont vains maintenant j'ai envie de dire
patrick c'est la règle des 5 dernières
minutes on est sûr on est sur le temps
de la fin et les débats ont été ont été
assez vif
j'ai essayé de te pousser pour sur
plusieurs thèmes différents mais pour
que finalement les questions qui se
posent décombres tout est sujet et de
prédilection et d' expertise mais aussi
de conviction et en tout cas c'était
franchement visible sur sur sur la
participation sur l'intéressement sur ta
vision de l'industrie que nous on a la
chance d'avoir tous les mardis matin en
réunion de groupe
mais là c'était différent c'était
vraiment pour que les autres puissent le
voir ceux qui suivent et participent à
ces moments qui sont quand même
privilégié à vos questions c'est un
moment vous avez un élu un ministre un
militant un comment dire une personne
qui comme moi comme patrie comme vous a
la conviction que
notre pays doit pouvoir continuer à
avancer à se construire en créant des
liens plus qu'autre chose
en pensant l'humanisme d'aujourd'hui est
finalement en en étant des humanistes
indépendant et européens
je crois que je n'invente rien en disant
ça patrick les dernières minutes sont
pour toi si tu avais un dernier mois
partagé en cette période
évidemment de second tour pour certains
territoires et à la veille d'un grand
moment parce qu'on attend évidemment une
la parole du président de la république
sur ce que sera l'après sur une période
où nous sortons mais toujours vigilant
d'une crise sanitaire
puisqu'on voit tout sur nos territoires
les fameux air 0 maintenant on sait ce
que c'est bouger finalement avec tout ça
patrick si tu avais une dernière phrase
1-1 derme peut-être un veut peut-être
une envie ce serait laquelle
1 prenez soin de vous parce que le coc
vide est pas tout à fait fini 2 bon
courage à ceux qui sont en campagne
municipale
parce que c'est pas les situations les
plus faciles quand on arrive dans les
dernières heures
vous dormirez vachement bien après quel
que soit le résultat croyez en mon
expérience
3 je crois qu'on a un très bon président
de la république mesdames n'attendez pas
tout de lui dit vous ce que vous pouvez
faire pour votre pays et je crois qu'on
l'a plutôt bien fait dans la crise
sanitaire et au fond cigare si un
message à faire passer c'est que c'est
que ce pays ait jamais plus beau que
quand ils cessent de se jalousent et qui
sait se rassembler et qui l'attend pas
qu'une vérité révélée viennent d'en haut
j'ai le sentiment que qu'on gâche de
l'énergie à trop se comparer et qu'on
ferait mieux d'avancer ensemble
merci beaucoup patrick il me reste plus
qu'à vous dire au revoir mais surtout
dimanche aller voter vous savez en tout
cas si uniquement si vous avez des
élections dans votre commune évidemment
vous avez compris le sens de mon message
et surtout rendez vous la prochaine fois
si vous avez envie qu'on invite
certains élus certains ministres hésitez
pas à nous l'envoyer par message c'est
aussi l'occasion de proposer et puis non
n'hésitera pas à participer envoyez
évidemment les invitations
l'idée c'est que ça se construisent avec
vous merci pour toutes les questions qui
ont été posées c'est que comme ça que ça
existe et que ce moment et pertinents
encore merci à toi patrick pour ce
moment pour ces échanges francs et comme
je vous l'avais promis au début vous
avez vu et pas de langue de bois